اتفاق بين بغداد واربيل على استئناف تصدير
نفط اقليم كردستان يسند للحكومه العراقيه
مهمه الاشراف الكامل على تصدير النفط من
حقول الاقليم التوقيع على مذكره تفاهم
سيسمح باعاده تصدير النفط مجددا عبر ميناء
جيهان التركي خلفيه الاتفاق دعوى قضائيه
لدى غرفه التجاره الدوليه رفعها العراق
للمطالبه بوقف تصدير نفط الاقليم الكردي
عبر تركيا من دون موافقه بغداد اي تاخير
في التصدير سوف يؤثر بشكل واضح على مجمل
الايرادات المتوقعه وبالتالي سوف ترتفع
نسبه العجز وهذا في ضرر بالغ لكل
العراقيين
المباشره بتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق سوف تقلل من
هذه المخاوف ان شاء الله
نهنئ الشعب الكردي والعراقي بهذا الاتفاق
الذي سيكون اساسيا في الموازنه وحتى قانون
النفط والغاز نتمنى ان يجري تنفيذه بشكل
جيد ازمات بغداد واربيل كان محورها الدائم
تصدير اقليم كردستان للنفط بمعزل عن
الحكومه المركزيه هنا منذ عام 2009 وحتى
الان الان غلب علي الطابع السياسي اكثر من
الطابع الاقتصادي
والاتفاق
الخلاف عن الاتفاقات السابقه انه زادت
الكميات المصدره التي تكون بعلم الاقليم
والمخصصه لايران من ايرادات الموازنه
العامه من 250 الف برميل الى 400 الف
برميل بدات بغداد بملاحقه تركيا واقليم
كردستان قانونيا منذ عام 2014 فقد اوقفت
الحكومات المتعاقبه واستانفت لمرات عده
هذه الاجراءات القانونيه وصولا الى كسب
القضيه في مارس اذار الماضي
بعد سنوات من التوترات بين بغداد واربيل
جاء هذا الاتفاق لينهي خلافات تاريخيه بين
الطرفين وهو ما قد يمهد الطريقه امام
اقرار قانون النفط والغاز
سامر يوسف الجزيره بغداد